good afternoon doctor sit down your
schedule has been cleared do not attempt
to leave the room until you are told
that this session is over the door is
already locked but it is crucial you pay
attention good you are now part of the
SCP foundations Ethics Committee this is
not a demotion sit down yes you're
terrified you think you're being
punished for some failure some lapse of
judgment some horrible disaster that
you're involved with you think that your
career with the foundation is over you
might even have thought that transferred
to the Ethics Committee is a euphemism
for killed this is not the case you'll
notice I said killed instead of
terminated that's a deliberate choice on
the ethics committee
we don't use euphemisms because of the
work that the SCP foundation does a lot
of personnel think that the idea of the
foundation having an ethics committee is
just a bad joke or they know that the
committee exists but they've got the
impression that we're an ineffectual
laughingstock a bunch of purposeless
seat fillers who wave a rubber stamp
that says approved and never dare to
voice an objection yes I see you've
heard the jokes here's one how many
members of the ethics committee does it
take to change a lightbulb
none the ethics committee can't change
anything no it's alright you're meant to
laugh we make an effort to sustain the
impression that we are useless because
we are the secret power within the SCP
foundation sit down
yes there are the Oh fines they judge
what isn't isn't safe and that's a vital
em important function but we are the
ones who advised the o5s on what is and
is not acceptable you've done horrible
awful things while working for the
foundation don't try to deny it
doctor we've all done horrible awful
things while working for the foundation
that is one of the unavoidable
consequences of working with s CPS and
on occasion you've wondered if we are
the quote/unquote bad guys well we're
not and that is because of the ethics
committee this is your first lesson do
you understand remember this the
foundation is not evil we do not torture
people just because we are against
unnecessary cruelty which means somebody
has to decide when cruelty is necessary
and that somebody is us stop trembling
it is important that you remember this
it is your second lesson the foundation
does not rule the world the foundation
serves the world do you understand what
that means regardless of what the
general population might think it wants
what we do what the foundation does is
in the overall best interests of the
general population
yes I'm sure you did realize that
already but you haven't thought of the
deeper implications
you've consoled yourself by forgiving or
the torture and murderers for the
greater good
this implies that there is a greater
good and a lesser good it implies that
there are multiple distinct Goods and
that these can be quantified impaired
this is what we on the ethics committee
do we are the ones who balance the moral
costs of everything the foundation does
and in order to balance these costs we
must know those costs do you realize
what that means doctor it means we know
everything the foundation does has done
and will ever do everything that has
ever been redacted or expunged we know
it every last detail yes including what
ICP 447 - - does when it comes into
contact with dead bodies yes we know
exactly what procedure 110-montauk is we
should we are the ones who designed it
now that's quite alright it's a culinary
action perhaps we shouldn't schedule
these meetings directly after lunch I
suppose here wipe your mouth you will no
longer be participating in active
research you may consider yourself a
researcher at large fitting from one
project to another from one site to
another at will this is not a secret you
are welcome to tell all your friends
that you have been transferred to the
epic security if you can deal with the
jokes in a pity you will observe what is
done and ask the participants and
yourself why it is being done if at any
point you feel that something is
excessive or unnecessary or wrong you
inform us we will summon the people
involved and ask them questions in that
meek ineffectual way your co-workers
have marked and then word will filter
down from the o5s through the many
levels of our bureaucracy and those who
are unethical will be given reprimands
which will be noted on their permanent
record or their pay will be cut or they
will be demoted or they will be
transferred to another project
or they will be shot for crimes against
humanity this is your third lesson
remember it the P stands for protect the
foundation protects humanity from ur CPS
and we protect the foundation from
itself we judge what is and is not
acceptable for the foundation to do we
balance evils so that on the whole and
in the long run
evil is minimized no you don't have a
choice about being on the committee yes
the irony is lovely isn't it